in the world of Tolkien's middle-earth
there are many differ
reaches and races but on this list we
shall show his to you the biggest
creatures that have appeared in his
works including the games and the movies
creatures such as gold rakes trolls
stone giants and many more are included
in the list some are as big as the
biggest animals we see on earth and some
even bigger than Godzilla himself even
dwarfing many other kaiju we did not
include the sentient humanoid races as
they will be shown in a different video
and as we have already done a video on
the seven dragons of middle-earth we
shall only list the dragons in one
category alongside many other creatures
so here are the 13 of the biggest
creatures in Tolkien middle-earth number
13 walks walks were a breed of wolves in
millet who lived in the Misty Mountains
and were captured and used especially by
orcs of Isengard and Mordor in the Third
Age the walks were not specifically evil
themselves they were known to be
exclusively used by or alongside goblins
sometimes asked death deeds in the books
walks are described as being giant
intelligent and malevolent wolves but in
the movies the eastern walk scene in law
of the Rings trilogy are noticeably more
hyena like in appearance an Eastern walk
measures about five feet tall at the
shoulder and could be up to eight feet
in length from snout to hindquarters the
biggest was the matriarch from The
Hobbit standing close to six feet in
height and greyish white in color number
twelve Balrogs Barack's also known as
the valid rocker were Meyer that was
seduced and corrupted by Melkor into his
service originally in unrecorded ancient
times the bell rocks were fiery Meyer
that were persuaded by malkos mind and
splendor to join his cause the first
dwelling was in M tum know but after the
Masters defeat during the war for sake
of the elves the bare rocks and other
creatures and malko service escaped and
went to an ban barrels generally took
the form of tall menacing beings roughly
in the shape of a man
though seemingly to consist or be
surrounded by shadow they are seen to
use both a flaming sword and a many
Truong whip and were constantly burning
with all their weapons having appeared
to be made of lava being twice the size
of a great health and an average great
health was deemed to be between seven
and eight feet tall
one could construe that a Balrog would
be on the average of 14 to 16 feet tall
but Doran's bane in the movie standing
around 20 feet or 6 meters in height
number 11 trolls trolls were very large
and monstrous beings ranging from
between 10 to 50 feet tall and for the
most part an intelligent humanoid race
inhabiting middle-earth Melkor created
trolls before the first age they were
very strong but turned into stone in
sunlight many trolls died in the war of
Roth but some have survived and joined
the forces of Sauron the greatest
surviving servant of Morgoth they were
strong and vicious but generally
dim-witted and stupid at best but some
were described as being able to speak
while others appear to be as irrational
as animals the major weakness of an Lea
some trolls was that they turn into
stone in sunlight their height was as
thick as stone and nyam pervious to
physical attacks there are many types
namely the mountain trolls the hill
trolls the two-headed trolls stone
trolls cave trolls half trolls snow
trolls and OLAP high with each type
differing in size and appearance
number-10 ends and also known as oh no
trembles are a very old racer appeared
in middle-earth at the same time as the
dwarves they were apparently created by
the behest of yavana
as she learned that owl is children the
dwarves knowing that they would want to
fell trees ends were envisioned as
shepherds of the trees to protect the
forest from offs and other barrels the
lsat tales of teaching the trees and
ends how to talk although the ends were
sentient beings at the time they did not
know how to speak until he elves taught
them and a tree like creatures having
become more and more like the trees they
herded they vary in traits from
everything to hide and size from 5 to 15
metres in height
and their coloring also varies
and the number of fingers and Joe's an
individual end more or less resembles
the specific spaces of tree that they
typically got number nine fell beasts
fell peas is a word referring to flying
creatures the nazgûl wrote after being
unhorsed at the fault of the brunnen in
the Lord of the Rings the fell bees
alike need to be distant relatives of
ancient cold rakes and grow up to
lengths of 30 feet and a wingspan of
more than 60 feet the fell bees were
described as large wicked creatures
without feathers and that had pinions in
between their horn fingers and whose
bodies gave off a stench it is possible
that fell bees came from an older world
the Dark Lord Sauron bred these fell
bees and gave them to his servants these
fill bees were powerful creatures and
were deadly offensive predators
especially with the nazgûl on them they
could choose either to bite their prey
or swoop down on them scattering the
enemies apart or outright crushing them
number eight the Eagles the great acres
were beings of harder said to have been
devised by man weight leader of the
Valar and were often called the Eagles
of manwë they were sent from Valinor to
middle-earth to keep an eye on the
exiled nor door and also upon therefore
the evil val armorr God and later upon
Sauron the great Eagles were messengers
and spice of the king of ardour and
possessed the ability to see through all
physical matter except for the blackness
of Margaret's evil pits for a time the
king of the Eagles thorn door kept his
ear is at the top of Teron Gor a dream
the tree mighty Peaks that more gods
raise from the iron mountains above the
gates of an man in the Third Age Thorin
dose descendants gwaihir and nan grovel
lived in an area to the east of the
Misty Mountains in the Wilderland they
have been noted to be around six meters
or 20 feet tall with a wingspan of no
more than 23 metres or 75 feet number
seven the Mumma kill miracle will large
creatures resembling elephants often use
in battle by the haradrim
holla fawn was a name given to them by
hobbits mimic will have an appearance
akin to that of an elephants pouring
thick arrow resistance
him and focal thus with +2 smaller tasks
behind the larger pair the miracles most
defining feature is undoubtedly their
vast size allowing the armies of model
to erect what hours on their bags
miracle are roughly eight times larger
than a real-world elephant they are
depicted as 35 to 45 feet tall each with
four to six tasks they were designed
after the extinct Probus ideon ballet
olufsen on antiquus otherwise known as
the straight dust elephant number six
the humans humans were a living race of
ancient slow-moving trees whom the ends
cared for and tended to in the 2nd and
3rd ages in middle-earth they were known
to dwell in the old forests and in
far-gone forests the humans mostly stood
as dark trees in the deepest forest
which green all and unmoving yet
watchful when aroused in wrath
they moved swiftly as if wrapped in
shadows falling upon foes with deadly
and merciless strength the tale of the
War of the Ring tells of how with the
ends to hew was march on Isengard like a
great forest and how under the direction
of the ends they exterminated the entire
of Legion in the battle of the Hornburg
the humans were very large beings in the
range of 10 to 30 metres tall or to the
tree to 100 feet in height
number five gold rakes gold rings were
dragons to lacked the great power of all
middle Earth's most infamous dragons the
ability to breathe fire nonetheless they
were strong foes with their iron hard
scales wicked cloths both tail and
terrible fangs though most were wiped
out during the war of rock at the end of
the first age many survived in the far
north
above the great mountains and in the
withered heat as the millennia passed
the cold Drake's multiplied and became a
serious trip to the dwarves in the late
centuries of the Third Age eventually
war was declared in two five eight nine
of the Third Age Dayne the first king of
the Durin's folk
and the second son floor was slain at
the gates of their own Hall by a
gigantic old rake these cold rains have
no exact figure of their size but one
can speculate that the big ones might be
as big a smog or even bigger
number four the stone giants the stone
giants were a mysterious race that lived
in the Misty Mountains and northmoor's
of middle-earth the origins of the
Giants are unknown as is the exact time
they first appeared in middle-earth
however it seems that they entered the
history of the peoples of the Middle
earth in the Third Age in the hobbit
stone Giants are described as hurling
rocks at one another as in a game during
a violent thunderstorm their physical
form was not described nor was much else
above them but in the first Hobbit movie
stone giants was seen and they were
extremely big standing more than 200 to
300 feet or 60 to 90 meters in height
they appear as hewn from stone and as
the size of Mount is being
undistinguishable from a cliff face when
they are still number 3 where worms
where worms were creatures told in the
stories of the hobbits though possibly
mythical where worms were thought to be
terrible monsters and made their home in
the last desert located far to the east
of the Shire
this large fearsome worms live in
underground dens in The Hobbit the
Battle of the five armies the werewolves
make a brief appearance before and
during the Battle of the five armies as
of andr gosh were leading the army to
walk through the tunnel which was dug by
the worms after Thor and Rhonda will
hear a rumbling noise below the
battlefield several where worms suddenly
burst to the ground near the hill
surrounding Arab world only to disappear
again soon after they seemed to be over
75 feet or 23 meters in diameter and a
visible length of at least 400 feet or
120 meters they are by far the largest
creatures in the third Hobbit film
number 2 ungoliant
and golden was a prime model taking the
shape of a gigantic spider she was
initially an ally of Melkor and Amon and
for a short time in middle-earth as well
she was the distant mother of Sheila and
the oldest and first giant spider of
Arda the true origin of ungoliant is
unknown and was not even known by the
banner just said that she came from the
darkness itself that lay about harder
and was once an ally of
when he looked down upon the world with
envy and golden size is also unknown
with her consumption of the power of the
trees and the wealth caused her to swell
to a size and shape so vast and hideous
that even Melkor began to grow afraid so
we can easily say that she became one of
the largest creatures to ever exist in
middle-earth but not as big as I'm
Galligan and the number one spot goes to
dragons dragons were ancient intelligent
and powerful creatures as feared as they
were admired in middle-earth their exact
origin is debated though it was clearly
stated that they were created by Morgoth
in some sense millennia before the
events of the Hobbit and a lot of the
Rings dragons lived throughout the 1st
2nd and 3rd ages of middle-earth and may
have lived even longer they were
originally bred by Morgoth during the
first age to serve as gigantic Shock
Troopers and mobile artillery the first
dragon ever seen in middle-earth was
glowering the father of the dragons the
biggest of them all was and Gallagher on
the black and the last was small the
golden their sizes vary greatly as for
example small is estimated to be over
200 feet long or 60 metres while and
Callaghan was the size of a mountain in
the range of kilometers and miles which
would put dragons as the biggest
monsters in Tolkien's middle-earth so
this concludes the end of the little
list make sure to LIKE share and
subscribe for more
monster related videos